foreign
this is this is a great anime mashup
we're hearing about your artists not
anymore right they changed it right are
they going to have a talking fast off
yes that was the initial narrative which
was a lie that's no they're gonna have a
[__] off that's the more challenging one
yeah let's do the context here yeah
you put out a video you mentioned look
at these fees
it's you know I I never mentioned money
outside of what I believe or immoral
penalty fees I never talked about you've
never heard me say hey not enough money
was offered that's not what it's about
so when we
then why did you ask for 30 million
dollars yeah why'd you ask for more
money and then also
is it saying I want to make all this
money and also have no penalties still
money yes right that's still money like
no no I want you to just pay me this and
then if I blow up the whole network
that's sorry
what am I Howard Stern I'll tell you
what here's here here's the counter
offer you say since it's not about money
you know what do me a favor take the
take a million off my contract I don't
want to be beholding to YouTube whether
I succeed or fail take it out completely
out of the mix right if it's not about
money right yeah that'll be less money
but it'll be less money but guess what
now I don't need to worry about what
YouTube does to me
by the way that's not defending shitty
contracts and by the way nobody hates
daily wire honestly outside of this
situation if you were to ask me who do I
who do I dislike more who do I think is
worse between daily wire as a
conglomerate or Stephen Crowder I still
think daily wire overall is worse and
it's done worse things that's not to say
Stephen Crowder is not also a grifting
[__] who like Mark Dice brought out
earlier he was fine when he was friends
with all of them when he was hanging out
and they were buddies when you when when
you were going to see that all the time
with these people oh we were you know
when they're friends and when they have
a falling out I've got years of dirt on
this person and it's like why why don't
you just walk away from I don't
understand why people can't just be like
yo you know what I mean I'm not cool a
person anymore we weren't the one going
to Dave rubin's gay baby shower Crowder
that was you like you understand what
I'm saying I don't know if the baby's
gay well we might be it by the end of
this well I mean um did you put an
Oxford comma in there it would work like
a gay baby shower a gay baby you're
right a gay comma baby shower not a gay
baby comma shower yeah or not showering
with gay babies either that's even
something else no okay good really you
really got to put the comma in now they
call it bidening [__]
yeah we first were watching the show and
we talked about it I said what's the fee
we don't know and then the daily wise
response of course was we offered this
guy 50 million dollars basketball money
basketball money the response then from
detractors and most people was holy crap
and they're imagining Stephen Crowder in
a big private bank vault diving into a
bunch of bullets when in reality
the 50 million dollars included the
entire budget for your whole staff your
whole production facility every
production you would have done meaning
you've got to pay that's still
I'm sorry
listen here guys who could afford salt
tanks now the thing will always choke up
about Joe Rogan right
even let me [__] explain something to
you okay coming from us us to here
do you know how we run this show do you
understand if we had 50 million dollars
do you know that we've been running a
[__] quality show by the way I think
better than any of these [__] all
right God imagine if we had like a staff
staff like I know we could actually like
pay employees be in an office picture
this and this is insane right because
we've seen with the daily wire office
looks like and we've seen all this other
[__] right and the blaze office is
another great one imagine what we could
do with just two people
physically in here just doing [__]
well I mean setting like actual like
just two people just two people that
just come in just boom and then while
you're live also go run pull things and
do into people that are in here and you
can pay them a salary and they're not
you know
you could be
no no but you're gonna get a whole
building full of people and they get on
the phone with the [__] CEO of
YouTube when they get a strike and
everything's all fixed
so wait so then so you're saying the
next logical step for you guys is you
have to have a falling out with me and
then I have to go on some I like I'll go
on steel toe
and I'll talk about how you guys were
mean to me and then well no that's not
fair you want to be you want to go on a
show that people watch okay
I go on the Dick show cry about you guys
and then promote my hummus brand
I like that yeah
how many employees you have
every are you gonna smash every chick
pee by hand
yeah I'm gonna Mash every chickpeas
matched by hand
you leave the sworn enemy of Chad
zumwalk alone and then I'm gonna the
Chad zumak who by the way to this day
still thinks he met me still thinks I'm
Royce and it's still been looking good
never read you never met him chat you
met me bud
Christ you've got to pay how many
employees oh he's turning him into Kevin
all right so you got to start immerse
you got to stop um you mean Neil
Brennan's brother
Marsh needs to you know what merch would
know this stuff more if he stopped going
on Chrissy Meyer's show all the time by
the way so we break it down 50 million
for five four years right so that's 12.5
million dollars a year even if you pay
yourself even if Crowder wanted to be a
[__] complete [__] spoiler alert
he does well I know but even if even if
ah you [__] [__] eating grin you
[__] he's right if
if Crowder even wanted to pay himself
eight Mill a year clean even with the
leftover money he should still have the
best show that's ever existed with the
amount of how much I know who rent he's
paying why does he let me see guys we've
seen his content can you explain to me
why he needs 25 employees to make what
he makes the content he makes when
you're buying [__] a bunch of BC Rich
warlocks and [__] every three months to
do a Kiss cover for [__] you know
kiss parody when you're doing my you
know my Corona and doing [__] you
know you gotta get the whole set you got
it you gotta pay for it you gotta pay
for that karaoke track because it's like
My Sharona but Corona you know what he
was underpaid he's gonna give him more
money
those bangers Banger after Banger
192 shows a year he needs 50 million
dollars to do 192. I would suck the
devil's dick wait not to get that much
money for a hundred and then to be like
wait and I'm penalized if I miss one at
least
192. if wait so if we get through this
12 months and I can't produce 192 talk
shows you mean to tell me I get
penalized [__] he couldn't know you
guys didn't understand 192 shows is hard
because there aren't that many The Knack
songs to parody oh and then we do a
yearly thing that we're going to produce
and if you miss that you're penalized a
million dollars but it's an event that
we're gonna fly you out first class
you're gonna have your hotels taken care
of your dinners it's all going to be a
write-off anyway and you can you know
probably have trists with your little
college boys
yeah and by the way whenever we [__] up
YouTube doesn't call us and ask us
kindly to get rid of something they just
give us strikes yeah they just gave us a
strike and then and then warn us if they
find another arbitrary reason to be mad
at us in the morning uh that we'll just
lose our whole account it really is man
it's like you and I have just been there
like we we we're F we're dropped we're
dropouts that just got into the [__]
military just to pay off just to be able
to afford school and then this guy comes
out of Westminster never served a
goddamn day shows up and he's like hey
guys with this nice little suit wow hey
we're all Brothers into arms go [__]
yourself he's a Pogue Crowder's a poke
he's just like you know what I mean he's
like a [__] officer that came out of
military academy and pretty much worked
in uh strata in the strata it's the
Strategic offices for a while
and we're the guy in the beginning of
[__] platoon when Charlie Charlie
Sheen's getting wheeled in and that guy
that guy's passing him on the Jeep and
he's just got the Thousand yards that's
how Dolphins had 250k a year per
employee is 25 million um I'll tell you
something with 100 certainty Crowder
does not play his employees 250 000 a
year I can tell you that he does not
paid do you think he's paid 250 000 a
year oh for for Landau I like to tell
you exactly how much they get paid but
you know those pesky ndas they make him
sign but they don't make sure yeah so
let's not [__] pretend like they're
making 250 000 why do you think [__]
quarter black air rolled the Dyson
bounced yeah I know you're right like
because that was a roll of the dice I
mean nerdronic does good [__] I know
their big Channel and everything but not
louder with crowd he left a [__]
Juggernaut I agree I agree with that he
left a juggernaut to go dude I need
they're doing great but why would you
leave to go do an indie thing that's
growing when if you were making if if
the big fat you know uh money bag Daddy
is actually taking care of everybody
there's no reason to leave right if he
were paying you a fortune and your
health care and all that [__] was
covered you'd be like yeah this is
bitching Ted Dominique has a very good
point he goes maybe Landau makes 250 000
maybe Landau it listen yes and I'll
explain why the only reason why I know I
think it'll be more explain this before
think about this Crowder's been missing
a lot of shows and the guy who's been
sitting in a lot for him his the main
replacement host is Landau so I'm saying
250k to be the backup guy I kind of get
that Lando Landau would still do that
for 150 a day because he's an idiot he's
a nice guy remember that's the team Dave
Landau he's a nice guy nice guy great
guy so I of course he's gonna just do it
you think he's gonna have enough
backbone to stand up to Crowder and get
a quarter mil maybe a hundred maybe yeah
maybe I'm gonna I'm gonna say 150. I'm
gonna go there
who the [__] is paying 150 grand for
landout but Anthony cumia
[Music]
tell you that
25 soon to be 30 something soon to be 30
something now if you wanted to land out
y'all caught the part where he [__]
about [__] one of his employees
getting poked too or the [__] daily
wire attempting to poach a [__]
employee from Crowder
did y'all see that did they really oh
yeah no they did they did they did no I
do remember this they they tried to take
his employees before the blaze thing
even happened did they yeah like like
producers and stuff yeah do production
on a skit we're talking maybe 30 to 50K
depending on the size of the skit yeah
every time you're spending 50 50K
there's no way to do shitty
[__] horrible that's a lie to get
people to give him more money he's
bearing there's no way in hell that it's
costing him 50k to do a [__] skit
that's [__] yeah
change my minus fifty thousand dollars
millions in legal yeah
to do one 's [__] if they throw all the
[__] lighting and [__] cameras and
[__] in the trash that's the end of
filming one let's start over and then
just start over
there's an equipment payroll uh millions
of dollars in taxes it's emerging it's
the merging of what was that it's theft
yes exactly let me just say wheelhouse
I'm I'm on your side on this one
everybody can know my bias the reason
that really bothered me is because I run
a company I know how much money we make
and there are people who assume that too
yeah but but you have a two million
dollar grip take but grip tape budget
like you understand what I'm saying and
most of that spent on guitar strings and
buying bots so people you think people
actually viewed your shitty music video
so get the [__] out of here Tim [__] out
of here all of these guys number two
never Trumper I'm the uh I'm the fence
guy I don't like you number two I
[__] like Crowder and I don't [__]
like I don't like any of these [__]
and honestly the more time has gone by
the less I like them because none of you
are [__] sincere all are you a
[__] garbage all right all your
opportunistic [__] which is fine okay
and the thing that always gets brought
up to us all the time every time we make
fun of these guys buy their [__] fans
it's like what are you guys jealous
actually not jealous as a matter of fact
we're doing pretty well considering we
never sold out to any of these [__] all
right considering we told them to suck
our dick all right so that's not what
this has ever been about all right this
is about phonies and these conscious
choices over the last five years to
avoid
like being around these people I mean
they're all backstabbing each other
every one of them are backstabbing each
other now everyone and anybody who's
gonna be like oh you go to Just Joel's
because you're not talented we were
offered seats at the table by all these
people at some point but it's like no no
thank you no it's like we don't even
want like how many times have has it
just been an invite to like a simple
get-together and we're like no thanks uh
but who's there though and then there's
always like four people on the list that
were like
nah
no I don't wanna food bucket food
buckets your food buckets
buy some food bucket sloth be amazed at
the [__] we've turned down hey guys just
go get MREs go look for them out about I
I can't because they're not Kosher so I
cannot get MREs and just keep a lot of
uh peanut butter and uh cocoa powder and
coffee you'll be fine yeah that's what I
learned from Steve MRE
peanut butter coffee powder and coffee
and cocoa powder and store it in a
drawer dry cool place it'll be fun what
does he always say
nice hiss nice nice very nice nice